you look familiar hmm I'm sure Jamie and
I are here to present this year's Oscar
for production design of all the
specialized arts that go into great
filmmaking designers are confronted with
the broadest range of possibility as
they imagine and create whole new worlds
our nominees this year include period
pieces and pure flights of fancy here
the nominees for achievement in
production design arrival production
designed by Patrice permit and stats
decoration like old Hawk fantastic
beasts and where to find them
production design by Stuart Craig and
set decoration by a mechanic Hail Caesar
production design by Jeff stone short
and staff decorations by Nazi Hague
la-la-land production design by David
Wasco and set decoration by Sandy
Reynolds Watson passengers production
design by guide Hendrik styles from
staff decorations by Jean Serena and the
Oscar goes to lala land David
[Music]
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for David Roscoe and Sandy Reynolds
Wasco
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
boy you can do it I share this
completely with Sandy my wife and set
decorator whose constant support and
talent have elevated my work over the
years and added special brightness to
lala land and Damian we wouldn't be up
here without you thank you so much
from our very first meeting together
with Lena Sangren and Mary Jo fries DPN
costume designer when you went through
each page of the script with us right up
to the planning of the scenery for the
finale and epilogue with Justin's music
and Mandy Moore's choreography you
shared your vision with such joy energy
and precision that we couldn't help but
have captured it thank you for your
enthusiasm you shared with us
[Applause]